all right joining me now is Robert Rea
former whitewater independent counsel
and John Eastman Claremont Institute
senior fellow and constitutional scholar
John the Democrats in the media were
sure just like in all these other
predictions that were flops as I just
pointed out they were sure that
yesterday's McGann ruling would compel
john bolton to testify and then Oh
Bolton's lawyer says not so fast
Democrats again are having to chase the
roadrunner and I'm going to end up with
a TNT blowing up in their faces well the
judge made very very clear that although
the top White House officials don't have
absolute immunity from even showing up
to testify that they can claim executive
privilege in response to specific
questions any time a question of
executive privilege arises and even have
the White House current counsel there to
advise them when to assertive privilege
so you know it may have sounded like a
win but they obviously didn't get past
page two or three of the twenty page
opinion I'm talking about Bolton this is
something that takes that analysis to
the next step Robert Rea they thought
John Bolton was going to be again that
the Nirvana and this whole you know
impeachment quest that they have but
Bolton's lawyers they don't seem like
they're in any rush to get up there to
testify get them up there to testify
either so they either they're either
really bad at making predictions or they
don't know the law or they don't know
how to read an opinion or that the
opinions limited to a certain set of you
know special facts I don't know what it
is but it's getting embarrassing now how
repeatedly wrong the Democrats are on a
myriad issues of issues well it's also
only one judge as you know Laura which
means that it's not binding on on Bolton
I mean let's just start with the very
basics right there and then the second
thing is is that the decision already
has been appealed that a notice of
appeal was filed today with a request
for a stay
I imagine we'll see that possibly as
early as tomorrow either by the district
judge or if the district judge doesn't
do it the
DC circuit circuit is likely to do it
for her so that what that means is that
on this timetable there's no way you're
going to have a decision from the DC
circuit that will make any difference
anyway yeah but it's like it's same
thing and I'm gonna get to Nadler in a
minute John but it's the same thing the
Supreme Court yesterday through Chief
Justice Roberts issued a temporary stay
in that financial records case which was
another attempt by the Democrats they
thought to you know throw a wrench into
Trump's reelection bid though we're
gonna need all these records that's
gonna look bad or I don't know what they
think but they've been in this again
this you know tilting at windmills
approach to Trump and at some point they
should just do better policy but that's
too hard for them they need to reread
article 1 the legislative powers not to
go fishing all the time and yet that
seems to be what they're doing to this
issue of Jerry Nadler because today the
Chairman Nadler of the Judiciary
Committee invited President Trump very
nice of him of the holidays and his
lawyers to testify but he also fired a
warning shot writing the following guys
while we invite you to this hearing we
remind you that if you continue to
refuse to make witnesses documents
available to the Committees of
jurisdiction the chair will have the
discretion to impose appropriate
remedies I'm sorry my stomach is hurting
because I was laughing so hard about
this earlier John I mean I don't know
what Nadler is threatening here but how
should the White House respond well they
ought to just say you know go ahead and
bring another suit and we'll take it up
to the Supreme Court again there's a
thing basic that mr. Nadler seems to
forget called separation of powers the
executive doesn't work for the
legislature this is not a parliamentary
system we have yes they have oversight
ability but these fishing expeditions
you know with with obvious political
motivations to try and dig up dirt on
their political opponent I thought that
was what not what we're supposed to do
is we got out of atoms here
at one point that what is the coal
penalty he has to get up the court to
impose a penalty correct Robert raised a
court look it's not like Nadler is gonna
get up get some US marshals to go over
to the White House and slap manacles on
the president and in his counsel I mean
it's most ridiculous thing I've ever
heard I know anything about the
separation of powers like law getting to
wonder yeah like when you look at the
remedies like what is he talking about
and in any event the executive branch
has a much bigger police force the
Capitol Police serve in the United
States Congress so I don't I don't
really understand I mean that's a
goddamn that's a pretty outrageous
threat against the president I have to
say there was a line in the in the
district court opinion though they
talked about inherent congressional
power of contempt to jail people in a
jail cell in the in the Capitol if they
don't show up to testify in response to
a subpoena so perhaps that's what he's
thinking about but it would be it would
be fun to see them try that against the
President of the United States threw
that one out there I must have missed
that John thank you that's why you know
you're still your professor now
television is all right guys thank you
so much great to see you tonight great
Thanksgiving